Hello and welcome to
"Two people about to make a mistake."
Why, Tom? Why?
Because a few weeks ago,
I was on Marques Brownlee's podcast.
We talked about doing this.
They had the sauces in the back.
And then we just went to lunch
and forgot about it, and I drove off.
And you remembered,
but now I'm here.
Well, I asked a few people,
(laughing) and you were
the first person who said yes!
I did say yes.
So this is my fault equally.
Entirely, entirely(!)
So the producers have sent over
a stack of questions and answers.
I've not seen these. You've not steamed
the envelopes open or anything.
I haven't.
No, these just arrived.
They're all estimation questions.
So they're all number answers.
Oh...
Furthest away in each round
tries that round's hot sauce.
We start easy.
We end up at this end.
And I really— The reason that we're
not just testing all the hot sauces:
First, lots of people have done that.
And second, I really don't
wanna do this one.
I really...
So that one's worse
than this one?
Every time I watch Hot Ones,
which by the way,
we don't have permission from them.
I hope you don't mind.
(both laughing)
We hope you enjoy the free publicity
that you really don't need.
Everyone taps out on
Da' Bomb, just here.
And the rest,
they're just too far gone.
That's the one I'm worried about.
How are you with hot sauce?
I've not ever—
I've done habanero hot sauce.
Mhm.
I don't know where that stands in this.
About two or three.
I am screwed.
(uproarious laughter)
So this is Hot Ones'
Classic Hot Sauce.
This is meant to be the mild one.
This is meant to be for everyone.
So, good luck.
I'll open question one...
...which have been decorated with little fish.
They haven't got numbers on them.
Is that on-theme? Is it a fish question?
I don't know.
I think they just had some fish stickers
and used them instead of numbers.
Alright.
"How many tennis balls are used
during Wimbledon every year?"
Oh my... god...
Yeah, this is not a brains question.
How many tennis balls are used
during Wimbledon every year?
And at Wimbledon, there's a lot
of matches that... several courts...
(soft groan)
Alright.
(laughs)
I think we're gonna have different
orders of magnitude answers here.
Ready?
Yeah.
Twelve thousand.
Ooh, eight.
Sorry!
(both laughing)
Eight thous— Okay, well we're both
in the same order of magnitude.
You know, it's—
Yeah.
No one's got a number in the hundreds.
No one's put 100,000 in there.
Do you wanna pull the answer?
If this is 10,000, we're in trouble.
What happens then?
We both do it.
Oh okay, easy.
I just made these rules up on the spot.
The answer is... (sputtered laughter)
...55,000.
Okay, we're both out.
But you were out more,
so the first one's yours.
Crack the bottle.
Okay.
We got tortilla chips
instead of chicken wings,
because A: we don't wanna
rip off their format entirely,
and B: these are much cheaper.
Good dollop.
Yeah, solid dollop.
Okay, down the hatch.
Graceful. (chuckles)
I would've put the whole thing in my mouth,
rather than trying to...
I'll do that moving forward.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, it definitely registers, that one.
Yeah? Alright.
Which is very worrying.
That's very worrying.
Question two.
"What is the equatorial circumference
of the Moon in kilometres?"
Okay.
Okay, I'm not immediately
panicking at this.
'Cause I know what...
I know roughly what the Earth is.
And...
I know roughly the gravity of the Moon...
(snorts)
I'm just— big numbers—
Like, this is—
Here's a question, do you think
you'll eat any sauce today?
I will be very surprised
if this isn't 50-50.
Through.
I mean, I heard some zeroes over there.
I've just realised that...
...I've written the exact same number
as last time. I've written 12,000 again.
I've written 8,000.
(laughs uproariously)
I have a horrible feeling
that this might be two-nil.
Because...
The Earth is what, like,
25,000 miles or something?
Yeah, it's like...
I was thinking it's about
30,000k, 40...?
That feels about right.
You've definitely got this.
I don't— I'm not sure I have.
'Cause the trouble with that is,
it's got a 'squared' in the formula.
I'll tell you this,
we're both very close.
But I'm ever so slightly closer.
It's ten thousand, nine hundred.
Ohh...
Dear, oh dear.
This is Adoboloco - Island Wings,
pineapple(!) cayenne pepper sauce.
You are very much going
in the shallow end here.
Now that shouldn't do too much.
That should be...
Yeah? Alright.
Definitely tastes of pineapple.
We've got water, we've got milk.
None of that coming into play yet?
Mm-mm.
Alright.
I'm just gonna pre-write 8,000.
(laughs)
Number three, this is a
Hot Ones brand sauce.
This is Los Calientes.
Ingredient number one
in this is chiles,
so we are already
quite a way up there.
Great.
Oh.
"How long is the first video
ever uploaded to YouTube?"
I remember what it was.
Yeah, I remember what it was.
They were at the zoo, weren't they?
Yeah, it was called "Me at the zoo".
Yeah, "Me at the zoo" or something.
"Me at the zoo."
Mainly for the So Solid Crew reference,
I've gone for 21 seconds.
Two minutes.
Ooh.
Was it that short?
Was it that long?
Ugh, it probably was
that short, wasn't it?
I don't know.
Why would you start with two minutes?
I don't know. I mean...
it's your answer.
(wheezes)
Eighteen seconds.
Yeah, I just thought they would've done
more at the zoo, you know?
Looks... There's no flushing
happening yet?
Not yet, no. That was...
You're all good?
Alright. Mhm.
That's sorta getting to...
Not a problem,
but it's becoming one.
(chuckles) Alright.
That was the first one that sort of
continued after I finished eating it.
But, still not too bad.
Alright.
Your question.
My question.
Heh. "Name the other Slow-Mo Guy."
(both laughing)
I just want one that I can win.
"How many people attended the
first festival held at Worthy Farm in 1970?"
So that's Glastonbury.
The first Glastonbury.
Is that what that is, Worthy Farm?
It wouldn't have been called Glastonbury.
They phrased that really carefully.
Well done to the question team,
'cause "first Glastonbury Festival"
I think is different to "first Worthy Farm,"
but I think Worthy Farm is Glastonbury.
If it isn't, that whole section
will have just been cut out.
This is the first one where...
...I have no idea
which ballpark to start in.
Same.
I mean, the comedy answer
is for me to put 12,000 down again.
(laughs)
But...
I think I'm gonna have to go...
I mean, it's a question for a reason.
It's gonna be an interesting number.
Or, maybe Glastonbury was just on
while they were writing these questions.
Alright.
So I did not go with the same.
I went with 1,200.
(snorts)
Eight hundred.
We both took a zero off.
It's almost like we've got the same
kind of brain for jokes and...
I don't know why
I put a comma there though.
I mean, I have a
horrible feeling... that...
if you'd gone just a little bit higher—
'cause I think it's actually gonna be way—
Now I've seen these numbers,
I'm like, that's gotta be...
It's gotta be more than that.
Surely it's gotta be more than that.
If you put anything higher than that,
I would be worried...
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
It's 1,500.
1,500.
Not a bad answer.
We're both— We're both right.
You invite someone on the channel,
and then you just treat 'em like this.
Sorry. Which hot sauce is this,
by the way?
This is...
This is Seventh Reaper.
Seventh Reaper, alright.
Does that mean there's Carolina Reaper in this?
Oh, it does.
Oh good.
(weak laughter)
That was a sarcastic "Oh good(!)",
just to be— just to be clear.
Alright, I'll say this to you now.
It's been a pleasure being on your channel.
Yep. Yep.
Has it though?
Up to this point.
But this may be one of
the last things I say.
Yep. Yep.
The thing about tortilla chips is,
you have to chew them, no matter what.
You can't just...
Yeah.
You can't swallow like a pill.
Mhm.
How're you feeling?
Doing all right.
Alright.
If you've ever thought
about learning to code,
then the free Fundamentals Camp
by this video's sponsor, Boolean,
might be for you.
Boolean is a tech academy
that can get you from zero
to building a basic website
in a few hours, for zero cost.
If you wanna get started with coding,
and after a few hours,
end up with something
that you can proudly say
you've made and completed yourself,
Boolean's Fundamentals course
is available on-demand,
whenever you're ready to begin.
Their full courses are live and online,
with actual instructors and projects.
They're for people who are
looking to start a career in tech.
You can choose between front-end development,
full stack, or data analytics,
with a money-back guarantee
that says,
if you complete the course,
apply to find jobs, and then don't get hired,
they'll refund you, or you can choose
to pay them only when you find a job.
But the Fundamentals Camp,
that's free.
It's an excerpt from
one of the full courses,
and if you've thought, "I wanna code,
but I don't know where to start",
that might be a good place to try
without any monthly subscriptions
or any payment at all.
Click the link in the description
to find out more,
and maybe start coding
your own website.
Right, back to the show!
(chuckles)
Question five— Oh.
I mean, it's called Burns & McCoy...
Mezcaline Oaxacan hot sauce.
I'll be crawling out of here today.
Mhm.
Trying to see if I have a sheen yet.
"How many words are in
Shakespeare's longest play, Hamlet?"
What font was he using back then(?)
(chuckles)
Quill.
I can't put 12,000 again.
I can't.
No.
(clears throat)
Shakespeare's longest play.
So it's...
That's a decent chunk
of a book, that, right?
How many words are on a page?
How many words can you say in—
How many words can
actors say in three hours?
Is it three hours? It feels about three—
It feels about five hours.
These are good questions.
These are really good questions.
'Cause they're all ones I feel like
I should know the answer to.
Mm-kay.
What'd you put?
80,000.
I put 25,000.
Ooh, okay.
So what's in the middle of these two?
The middle of these is...
50-something thousand.
And it is...
It's 30,000. Sorry.
Hell!
(wheezes)
Hell's bells!
I'm really sorry, Gav!
I just gotta get better at guessing!
These were the ones
I wanted to try, Gav!
These are the ones that are like,
"I'll do these. These are fine."
These are the ones I'm worried about!
And then... mmph!
Sorry!
So that's the end of the front half.
This is... This is
normally still reasonable.
I think this one was worse, y'know.
Really?
Slightly.
I mean, the biggest ingredient
in that one was tomatoes, so...
Hmm.
The next one is
Collards N Ghost.
This is collard greens
and ghost pepper.
Good.
I remember being in Alabama
with Destin from Smarter Every Day.
Love him.
And...
...he was impressed I knew
what collard greens were.
They're not a British thing.
No, I'd never have...
I've never had them until I came here.
Same with, like, grits and such.
Yeah.
(whispers) God...
(both laugh)
"How big is the world's largest IKEA,
in square metres?"
In square metres?!
Oh...
Square metres.
So you've gotta take...
You gotta work out
how big it is,
and then like, multiply...
What's a football pitch?
I actually don't know
how big a soccer field is.
I know an American football field
is gonna be 100 yards,
which is about 100 metres.
So that's gonna be about 100 by 30.
So that would be... 3,000.
I feel like I got my maths
wrong there. Is that right?
A yard is what, 91 centimetres?
A yard, at this level of estimation,
yards and metres
are about interchangeable.
Part of me is like, I need to...
...I need to absolutely get some...
...get some hot sauce down me
in this video, or I just look smug.
I need a comeuppance here.
But also...
Part of me is wondering
if I can clean-sweep this.
Because I'm really over-competitive.
Have to redo the intro, about the
two people about to make a mistake.
Yeah.
800,000.
(stifled snicker)
(chuckle pop)
I've done... I bet the smallest one
is bigger than that.
I thought— I figured a kilometre
by nearly a kilometre.
And now that seems
way too big in my head.
So 1,000 by 1,000 would be a million.
Would be a million, yeah.
It might be more than a million.
This might be the worst guess I've had.
65 thousand.
I was way out!
I was way, way out!
Really?!
65 thousand square metres.
I feel like IKEAs are bigger than that.
You get lost in them!
Yeah, it's very hard to—
I was thinking, there must be
a massive American big-box store.
I was thinking kilometre by...
No, it's... You're spot on.
Right!
It's very hard to comprehend
when there's a square involved, I feel.
Okay.
Oh, the clean sweep.
I'm so relieved. Oh boy.
This is— This is phenomenal.
I'm so glad you invited me on this.
Also I'm coming in at
hot sauce number six here.
I've had no warmup.
Alright, Collards N Green hot sauce.
Oooh.
Alright, that's...
That is a lot.
You're going off the deep end there.
And I kinda want to pour some of this off,
but I can't reasonably do that...
...at this point. No, no.
I think you should be allowed.
We gotta— Here we go.
Okay.
Good night, Tom Scott.
Oh, that tastes lovely.
Good?
Mmm.
I mean, they are meant
to be food, aren't they?
They can't be all horrendous.
It's...
It's not mild. I'll say that much.
That's not mild.
(giggles)
It tastes delicious.
They've made a really good hot sauce.
It tastes like collard greens.
That hits the back of your throat...
...really quickly.
Yeah.
And really strongly.
And I think that's a factor—
I can feel... that flush.
I don't know if you can see it.
Are you getting
the clagginess happening?
Yeah. Alright!
Excellent!
Hooh!
This video's heating up.
That's a... good hot sauce.
Kinda already want
some of the water, but...
I'll keep going.
Number seven is...
Tyrfing's [tear-fings], Tyrfing's [tyre-fings] Curse?
Yeah, Tyrfing's [turf-ings] Curse.
Alright, ingredients:
yellow red pepper,
red onion, vinegar,
baby carrots, orange juice...
Where are the chiles?
Apple cider vinegar...
Oh, here we go. Habanero,
ghost pepper, scorpion pepper.
My tongue's on fire.
I didn't like the last bit of this.
No. I didn't either.
That's... mmph.
Weirdly, the underside
of my tongue is on fire.
Interesting. How'd it get under there?
I don't know.
I've noticed, very liquidy.
I did make the mistake,
and I don't know if you saw.
And I don't know why I did this.
I got the chip...
and then I turned it 180 degrees and
poured the hot sauce directly on my tongue.
I don't know why I did that!
Number six is a hell of a thing
to come in on. That's...
Yeah. I don't envy you
on that one.
"When was the first
electronic spreadsheet invented?"
Hmm.
I read an article about this
a few months ago,
and I can remember
none of the details!
It's gonna be for one of the...
early, pre-PC things, isn't it?
We probably shouldn't talk to each other,
get the ideas on here, but...
So I... I was torn here.
I thought it might be, like, Lotus 1-2-3
or something like that for early Macs,
in which case I've gone way too early.
But I feel there might be something like
Sinclair Spectrum, or something like that.
So I said 1981.
(long wheeze)
Ah.
(joins wheezing)
Well...
Your answer. Let's...
No, what were you thinking?
I just thought it'd be some sort of...
somehow electromechanical
thing that they figured out.
Maybe?
'Cause it would've been after the...
graphical user interface, wouldn't it?
No, 'cause I was thinking,
you can do it on a keyboard.
Just with characters?
Yeah.
Whew. 1979.
(slow exhale)
You are on it!
I'm on it.
I just assumed it would be
a pretty extreme answer, but...
you know, impossible.
Tyrfing's Curse.
So that was the worst answer yet,
I think, for me.
(snicker)
I mean, I did say the biggest IKEA
was nearly a million square feet, so...
When I miss, I miss hard.
I missed by a couple decades there.
Alright...
Here we go.
(both wheezing)
I mean, you're not immediately
yowling in pain, so...
I think I might be all right.
Okay.
You can just feel the...
It's like you can feel
the upward spike.
And you don't know
where it's gonna land.
Yeah.
So some of them are coming like...
I think that one's...
Alright.
We're on number seven.
There's no water, there's no milk yet.
I'm proud of us.
Maybe we should start adding
a little more as we get up there.
I guess?
That's gonna come back
to haunt us.
Oh, that one,
I'm really feeling it on the...
Okay.
...uvular area.
Oh, hang on.
It's Da' Bomb.
Da' Bomb Evolution.
This is the one
that kills every interviewee.
This is the one that—
The first ingredient is red hot chili peppers.
"What was the average
temperature of the Earth
during the 20th century,
in Celsius?"
Huh.
I don't know.
I'm wondering if—
You've got a lot of polar...
I wonder if the poles really skew
the average to a nice medium.
I was thinking that.
And also you're gonna have...
It's an obvious thing to say,
you're gonna have a lot of winter.
Yep.
I'm just very surprised to find that...
Do you know what percentage of the
population is in the northern hemisphere?
Oh, I mean, if that's a question
coming up, I'll be impressed.
(giggles)
But I'm gonna assume it's high 80s, 90s.
Yeah, it's almost 90.
Yeah.
Okay, hang on. We...
I'm just gonna pick the most average place
I can think of in terms of weather,
and pick the most average
weather that it could have.
I'm thinking mediocre
autumn day in Milton Keynes.
Thirteen.
Nineteen.
You probably have this.
I'm not sure.
I was just in the back
of my head, thinking like...
Singapore, and...
I think...
I think I've got it wrong,
'cause deserts.
Deserts. Although,
very cold at night, a lot of them.
That's true.
So, if this is sixteen...
Double bomb? (giggles)
Double bomb!
Sorry!
(strained) It's 13.9!
It's an average...
It's a mediocre autumn day
in Milton Keynes!
Gav, I'm sorry. I really am.
Honestly, I can't be annoyed,
because you're so close to these answers.
You are within one degree of that.
I wasn't planning this. I swear.
I assumed this was gonna be 50-50.
It's the worst case scenario,
'cause it's not 50-50.
And there's no clean sweep.
No, no.
So it's really just as bad
as it could be for me
without being a clean sweep for you.
Yep.
Which like, in terms of,
inviting guests onto this channel,
being a good host,
appearing graceful
and not smug on camera...
It's also— I'm not in physical pain.
But let me tell you, emotionally,
and from just sheer awkwardness,
I feel terrible.
I feel really bad.
All I'm learning is that for
round two of this,
when we eventually do
another collaboration,
I get to pick the game.
Yeah.
(snorts)
Mm!
I didn't even have my nose over it.
That has just set every saliva gland
in my mouth into overload.
Like someth— Oh my god!
Holy (bleep)!
Okay, yeah. That's...
A little bit of that.
Yeah. That is...
That's a solid choice. That's...
Sorry, I swore there.
That's okay, we'll bleep it.
I suspect we'll be doing
a lot more bleeping very shortly.
Um...
Good— Good night.
(strained)
Talk it through. What's it like?
It's wet at the moment.
Okay. This is not immediate.
Oh my god.
Okay! (wheezes)
(whispers) This is bad.
Okay.
Oh, it's still going up.
Oh no.
Oh god.
And I've just swall— (cough)
Just gonna...
I'm trying not to grin too much.
Honestly, it's still going up.
This is— This is the one
I didn't want. That's...
(deathly shudder)
If— (wheezes)
I have to reset my whole scale!
Okay!
Everything else was a one!
My tongue's getting bigger.
(chuckles)
(shudders)
It's expanding. (cough)
...all around! (hack)
It's climbing the walls.
I can't open my eyes!
I think it's still building, y'know.
There's a lot of spit happening.
Okay.
(clears throat)
'Kay.
I wanna move and run around.
Mhm. Yeah, take a—
Walk it off.
Yeah, maybe a little stroll.
Just a little. (ahem)
The middle of my vision is good.
Yeah.
All of this is fuzzy.
Really?!
Like a snowy sort of...
What's— So the next one after that
is less than that?
It's meant to be.
Whew...
I feel like I wanna hiccup.
I just— (sigh)
Just don't know what the—
Do you need water?
what the most comfortable position is.
(chuckling) Seriously, are you okay?
Okay.
Maybe a...
...Water? Milk?
I'm gonna try for— (cough)
I just wanna see if I can...
Yeah.
...get to the top of the hill without it.
Yeah. Okay.
But um...
I might be over the hump.
Okay.
That went and invaded
my entire face.
Yeah, it— (chuckles)
I can feel it moving
through the veins of my face.
The first words you said were:
"It's— It's just wet."
And then... (chuckle)
(wheezing)
Then— Then it went places.
Yeah. I'm gonna have a little sip.
Yeah.
I think water can make it worse.
Is that right?
I don't know.
I guess we'll find out.
Okay so— (ahem)
The problem is just trying to shift
the rest of it, the residue.
Mhm.
Ooh, there's little pockets of it.
(shaky exhale)
(wheezing)
So now we know that if you are
doing a Hot Ones taste test,
You can start at, like, five.
You can start there.
Yeah, these are just — (ahem) — nice.
Those are just nice hot sauces.
Some of these were worrying.
That had a bit of a kick,
but it went very quickly.
That—
Yeah, one of these got me worried,
'cause I could feel the potential
it had, and then it sort of...
And it just left the building.
Alright.
"How old was the
oldest dog on record?"
I assume it's in human years.
Typically—
Although that's actually a clue, isn't it?
They say, what, a dog year is meant to be
seven of a human— or is it nine?
Yeah, but you think of some cats
who can push about eighteen, I think.
I don't know why I'm trying to give
you some benchmarks here.
A lot— Wait, as of what year?
As of now?
I assume that, "How old was
the oldest dog on record?"
So I assume that—
I was gonna phrase this less—
I was gonna phrase this more delicately.
I assume it's dead now!
This is a complete gap in my knowledge,
'cause it's about animals.
I don't know how long...
I don't know how long a dog lives.
I should know that.
(sigh) I'm gonna regret this.
I'm gonna say 32 years.
Because I feel like that's
the end of the bell curve,
the longest they could be.
I think you've got this, 'cause
I've gone more conservative with 26.
I mean how long... like...
How long does an average dog live?
I don't know. I think...
I think sadly it's not as long as a cat.
It's... your answer.
This is— This by the way is for
Dingo Psycho hot sauce.
Fifteen out of ten heat warning.
29 years and five months.
I think that's your hot sauce.
Why did it have to say
five months?
(both wheezing)
Oh mate, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Ogh...!
I could've just put 27.
You could've just turned this down.
I've just touched my eyes.
Oh no! Oh no!
(laughs uproariously)
I think I'm all right.
I just put my fingers in my eyes.
(both giggling)
Gav, I'm so sorry!
Aah.
I didn't...
Aah. You must have...
...smarter YouTube friends
that you could've brought on
for a more equal game.
I didn't—
(giggles profusely)
The smart ones said no!
I genuinely thought you'd be
better at this than I am!
Yeah. I'll see you over there.
Yeah.
Sorry.
(clears throat)
(snorting choke)
(hacking)
I'll describe this before
I can't speak.
Yeah.
Imagine a small steamroller.
(wheezes)
But the flat roller is
small knives...
Yeah. (snicker) Yeah.
...slowly driving towards
the back of the throat there.
That was a full-force arrival...
...but it had no mass to it.
I swear they don't put the
strongest one at the end!
Well, the last one is the
Last Dab one that they do, right?
Yeah.
(ahem, gulp)
I mean, that was
by no means mild.
Yeah.
If I was rating them so far,
it'd be everything up here,
This would be on this side of this.
Yeah.
Alright.
So what happened there is...
...if I can describe this one...
Yeah.
It was, you know, really slow.
Didn't really understand
where it was going.
Mhm.
This one came in much higher.
Yeah.
Just never got to the same height.
Alright!
So that was more worrying.
But much more relieving.
And you're still not on the milk.
Still not on the milk. (ahem)
I feel like I am getting
some sort of stacking effect
from the last two.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
But I think with that one,
I think I got away with that.
Mind you, the ice cream's
sitting here melting at this point.
Yeah.
You got the eraser.
Let's go for the Last Dab.
So this is
The Last Dab - Apollo,
made with the Apollo pepper,
the new world record
hottest pepper.
But look at the liquidy...
Yeah. Yeah.
The viscosity of that one.
Okay!
"What is the current fastest
speedrun time of Super Mario Bros.
in minutes, seconds,
(ahem) and milliseconds?"
I know nothing about video games!
Really?!
The only clue in that is milliseconds.
So I— Honestly, my first thought
on that was like...
...half an hour.
But it says minutes, seconds,
milliseconds.
Speedruns, sort of stopwatch-based
a lot of the time, aren't they?
So they just stop the clock and...
Yeah.
(ahem) And sometimes,
even if it—
Minutes, seconds, milliseconds.
Even if it's half an hour,
you might get people ending
around the half an hour mark,
which is why milliseconds are important.
Okay. Oh yeah, okay.
Is what I'm trying to say. (sniffle)
Okay.
Which—?
(sigh)
I'm trying to visualise...
I don't know where to start with this!
There's gotta be warp pipes involved.
...Sure.
So, you really don't play games?
I played video games
when I was a kid.
I think...
it's been ten, fifteen years
since I seriously played
anything, and...
I was never a console kid.
Right.
So, I don't even know...
(heavy worried breathing)
In hindsight, I should've
gone for a funny number.
I should've put like...
Twelve.
I should've either done 12,000,
Twelve milliseconds!
or I should've gone for,
like, 69-something,
but what I've done is
I've gone for 24 minutes,
and then just put some
random numbers on the end.
Okay, I've gone for
three minutes twenty.
(snort)
Mm. I feel— (laughs)
I feel like... I might know
how this one ends!
(titter) I don't—
I know I've seen some
Mario games very done fast.
I just don't know which one
that was I watched.
So what I need here
is for this to say...
Like, over fifteen is where
I'm starting to look good.
That's...
HAH!
Yeah. It's just under five minutes.
That's...
(heavy relieved sigh)
(growling sigh)
It's over for me!
It is.
It's not for me.
That is a significant dab.
(stammering)
You're going all-out.
You've got to. You've got to.
I can't go half-assed on this,
can I?
No, I guess not.
It is YouTube after all.
...Oh.
Seems pleasant maybe?
I see why you said it's just wet.
There's nothing—
(coughing profusely)
(cackling)
Haah! Haah!
Seriously?
(frantic gulping)
I was almost disappointed!
(breathless chucking)
D'you wanna go have a walk by the paint?!
(heavy panting)
aaoOOOWww!
That takes ten seconds,
and then...
That was interesting.
Oh!
Your reaction at the beginning was...
Almost disappointment, even in you.
Mmph!
AAah!
So...
I'm gonna dial 9-1,
just in case.
The subtitles team...
that we have for this channel...
do a really—
No, milk. I'm—
On the milk!
Mmm.
I couldn't be happier.
The subtitles—
team do a great job.
AGH!
Because... I had to
ask them to calm down...
'cause they — (gluck)
— they over-describe stuff.
Like...
The subtitles should not
distract from the content.
So—
(retching cough)
I can hear it in your throat actually!
Get that milk down.
Do you feel all right?
But in this case, subtitle team...
...go on... go ahead and...
...just add all the
descriptive stuff you want...
...in these vocalisations!
(chuckles)
"Wet blubbering".
(pained groan)
(giggling)
(loud gulp into retching moan)
Is it just continuing to build,
or is it...
Do you think you're
over the hump?
(mouthing "It's going up")
(giggling)
(pained whine)
Haah!
I still feel mine.
I can't imagine what you're
going through right now.
Do you wanna get the
ice cream going?
Yes!
Haah!
(panting) For both of us.
We should have pre-opened this.
(anguished shout)
(giggling)
Let me take care of this.
It just...
(inner burp) Ugh.
(wheezing giggles)
Ooh, that's nice and soft.
Well, you won't struggle
with the... the plastic spoon there.
It has been waiting there,
like, half an hour.
Oh, that's just—
That's liquid. Cool.
Okay, that's just...
(shivering moan)
Yeah, I'll give it a go.
Why not?
Mmm.
I'm good.
See that's fine. That gets rid of—
Can you pass the— the kitchen roll?
Aah...!
It just comes back. It just—
(bellows)
(shouts)
(tired moan)
We've come a long way.
(hoarse) Uh-huh.
Thanks, Gav.
Anytime.
Never again.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]